alright guys so it is Oscar night and I
decided no one said I'm just doing a
predictions video and a reaction to the
winners video I'm going to do it all in
one I'm going to film myself while
watching the Oscars before they announce
the winner I will say woo my prediction
is and then I'll give you my reaction of
the actual winner and this will be fun I
just want to add that currently right
now Inspector Gadget starring Matthew
Broderick is on Cartoon Network I love
my life
and just let you know I'm not really
going to be reacting to every single
award or the hosts or whatever you know
all that stuff I'm just gonna be
focusing mostly on the major award
categories okay I just freaking freaked
out like a fanboy when Tom Cruise came
on that was just awesome his little
Mission Impossible appearance because
Mission Paz wasn't even really nominated
I don't think for anything okay they
just showed a clip from Twilight at the
Oscars officially the Oscars has nothing
to me anymore it's gone all respectful
well I'm gone everything gone everything
is gone now Oh Joss that's good that
saves it so people are telling me
apparently that JLo had a nip slip I
didn't notice but I can assure you that
I will be checking on various sites
later for information about that and
photographs here so Best Foreign Film is
coming up and I'm just gonna say
separation pretty sure that it will come
up I have no idea what other film could
possibly beat it it's all I ever hear
about so a separation separation
I can't even begin to take any credit
for knowing that because not only have I
not seen the film but it literally is
the only film I ever hear about Best
Supporting Actress my prediction is
Octavia Spencer I would also like
Octavia Spencer to win I would have
picked shailene woodley but she wasn't
nominated but I'm going with Octavia
Spencer that's who I would like to win
and that's who I think is going to win
so far it's fairly easy to predict these
I'm glad that she won she was great in
the film I think she's really humble and
just awesome like I said it would have
fixed shailene woodley overall but she
wasn't nominated but Octavia Spencer
good for you you did a great job
I'm happy for you okay I want to grow
the drug tattoo to win for best editing
because that was the one of the fastest
pace 3-hour movies I've ever seen the
editing was pristine it was fantastic
I could I immediately thought of the
editing while watching that movie
awesome I didn't think that that would
actually win because like I'd never know
what I want never wins that that
deserves it that film was great that the
editing in that movie was just perfect
out of all the films that are nominated
for Best Picture tonight to be honest
Hugo's the one I like the most out of
all of them all right best animated
feature film I would like Rango to win
and I believe that that is the one that
will win even if Tintin had been
nominated which makes sense to me I
still would've wanted Rango to win and
that is my pick
nice I am very satisfied so far in my
pics as well as the awards okay
visual effects thinking about the
nominees I would really like a Harry
Potter one it deserved way more
nominations than it did way way more way
more been nominated for Best
Picture for sure however I have a
feeling that Rise of the Planet of the
Apes is going to win great work by Wetty
really realistic in fact I might
actually be kind of tied in my mind
between Apes and Potter in regards to
what I would actually want to win but I
think Apes is gonna win why are they
showing Michael Bay I shut up
okay Hugo was very good but I'm not
feeling like the effects of Hugo were
more impressive than the things I saw in
Harry Potter and in Planet of the Apes
that's just my opinion
good job Hugo you're a great movie but I
disagree with that one okay so we're
going into Best Supporting Actor now I
personally would like if Nick Nolte
would win that would be who I want to
win however I am going to predict the
Christopher Plummer will win that's not
really that hard to predict
you know you and McGregor was great in
beginners I would have liked to see him
get nominated I just saw Thomas horns
face and I winced and now I need to go
to the bathroom
so far I'm not getting too many
surprises here look at him he's rowing
up the steps he was great he was great
in beginners fantastic he was very very
good okay this thing is worth Billy
Crystal and saying what people are
thinking is brilliant
so Best Original Score now now I'm
thinking that the artist is going to win
because it's basically a movie that is
literally non-stop music which is very
impressive if I figured that would win
and like I said it deserves it it was
very good
in regards to the fact that basically
carried the entire movie it was nonstop
music and I had to keep it going and it
did a good job of doing that so once
again pretty predictable show so far but
you know that's kind of just how it goes
sometimes okay so now we have Best
Original Song and I'm going to just
assume that one of them is going to be
the Muppets because there's only what a
couple nominations so let's go with man
or Muppet once again not surprising but
good job Best Adapted Screenplay and I'm
going to pick the descendants as my
winner and it's also the one that I
would like to win because that film was
just written so well
the descendants now we have best
screenplay in general and I still
perplexed by why the artist is nominated
I understand it's a great story but
sorry it's more difficult to write
dialogues it really is I have a feeling
that Midnight in Paris is going to win
and the script was great great script
really liked the movie and I think
that's gonna win and that's who I would
like to win also very good of course
Woody Allen the ultimate hipster is not
there millio of itch is presenting at
the Oscars she's beautiful she's sexy
but apparently all I got to do to
present the Oscars is starring as long
string of crap directed by her husband
well for Best Director obviously I would
have loved if Nicolas Winding Griffin
was actually nominated but for all the
people who are nominated now I would
prefer Martin Scorsese to win because
his film was the one I like the most out
of the films that were nominated for
directing however I have a feeling that
Michelle hasn't a vicious is gonna take
it and I think I actually said that
right
as I said Michelle hazanavicius would
have loved discourses you took it though
Academy so Best Actor my personal pick
out of all the people who are nominated
for Best Actor is George Clooney however
I'm gonna say that Jean Dujardin is
gonna take it I'm gonna say it that's
what I thought I'm serious I I'm fine
with him he was great in the film I
think Clooney gave his best performance
I've ever seen I would have liked Gary
Oldman because I loved Gary Oldman but
he was great too okay so now we have
Best Actress in this category I would
love to see Rooney Mara win she's my
pick I would love if she wanted
performance was so effective however I'm
pretty sure that Viola Davis is going to
win there's a possibility that Meryl
Streep might win though because a lot of
people been talking about that but I'm
gonna go with Viola Davis for winner
[Music]
well that ends my streak and that makes
me a little disappointed come on
Viola Davis made bridges with her
performance she she just
it's true nice Tom Cruise for that Best
Picture that's pretty cool
he looks the same juice man does not age
he looks the same there are so many
reasons one day I would look like that
man
in regards the best picture out of the
films that were nominated the one I
liked the most was Hugo but I'm not
thinking it's gonna win I'm thinking
it's between Hugo and the artist I'm
thinking it's gonna be the artist so I'm
gonna say the best picture is going to
be the artist because in Academy
tradition the film that wins Best
Picture is generally okay generally the
film that is you know most relevant at
the time and not the one that we
remember forever that's usually how it
goes
we remember movies not Academy Awards
case in point 1994 Forrest Gump won for
Best Picture but that year also had pulp
fiction and the Shawshank Redemption
which films are more remembered so
that's my prediction for Best Picture
however I would prefer a few though one
because that's my favorite out of all
the nominees
as I said I don't want to look like a
d-bag but this show was very predictable
for me anyway I was able to predict a
lot of these but I don't really feel
like that saying much these were a lot
of these pics were very obvious the
artist was a great film
great job artist very good it wasn't my
favorite out of the ones that were nom
but it was a great film so a good job
for you artist overall I actually really
liked the show I thought it was a lot
better in the past few years Billy
Crystal was great the the production was
really good I thought the Oscar did a
really good job this year I wasn't a
huge fan of lot of the nominations a lot
of things were left out a lot of things
were added that I didn't think should
have been there ie Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close a lot of things I would
have liked to have when didn't but it's
alright you know whenever at least we
have the you reviewers Awards right
thanks a lot and as always if you like
this you can subscribe to my channel and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]